New York City is telling these Pizzeria
that they need to cut their emissions by
three quarters you're gonna come after
Pizzeria that's the Department of
Environmental Protection new rules that
say that Wood-Fired good pizza places
need to change the way that they make
pizza or they're going to be shut down
by the city now this ain't gonna happen
they're saying that there are harmful
pollutants in neighborhoods with poor
air quality and we need to control
emissions because people are going to
choke on the pollution of a delicious
tasty Pizza I wish that I had the the
emissions from a delicious pizza place
down the street or downstairs from my
apartment how wonderful would that be
that would be the most delightful
fragrance that I could imagine in my
apartment but instead they're saying
that's a very bad thing and everybody
hates the smell of pizza of course and
that's why we're going to shut down the
pizza shops you come for them I'm coming
for your throat the reason that they're
going after your pizza is not because
your pizza is causing global warming
they're going after your pizza
specifically because it will make you
suffer specifically because it is a
sacrifice because sacrifices and
suffering are an important part of
religion